the customary cheering at the opening
bell on wall street couldn't mask the
fear felt by many investors at the start
of trading news of russia's invasion of
ukraine sent stocks tumbling following a
global trend that also hit asia and
europe the dow and s p were deep in the
red most of the day and despite a late
rally investors for the long term are
fearful
in russia stocks fell over 30 percent
and the ruble dropped to a record low i
think vladimir putin has essentially
decided to put glory and imperial
conquest and also revenge ahead of the
economic prospects of his own country
and fellow russians that's the simple
calculation he's made making matters
worse the global economy was already
unsettled still trying to recover from
the economic effects from the pandemic
inflation continued supply chain issues
and slower growth
and now a war
in many ways it's the perfect storm
oil prices reached over one hundred
dollars a barrel for the first time
since 2014.
russia is the world's second largest
exporter and analysts predict that along
with supply chain issues the war could
push prices at the pump even higher than
they are now
prices for european natural gas most of
which is supplied by russia skyrocketed
50 percent wheat and corn prices jumped
to their highest point in a decade both
russia and ukraine are major producers
and consumers might ultimately pay the
price in more expensive food products
with the global economy now shaken from
war the question is no longer if there
will be a downturn but now how deep and
for how long gabriel rosando al jazeera
new york